all right so what do the monkey know two
cups of flour sugar baking powder a
little bit of the tablespoon of sauce
fun food I like to eat like bugs
I like to add the flour so I just
incorporate the evenly Anders heart and
there's like lunch when you need good
yo this is flaxseed I like using going
it foxy cuz it digests better but I have
a fat see you want to put some other
kind of feed your chair seat at 3
tablespoon of that
GSE and then we put in some sugar 2 tbsp
of sugar then we have a coconut the
coconut from the Kokomo should
tablespoon coconut
are you a good fear the iodine a time
I'm good fats in it and we you see use
coconut
I don't you make a lot groaning this is
almond milk but you gives you in can you
do some time in quit you know you can do
water you can use water much cows to cut
you know let's mix it up first and make
sure to perform similarly does like
nobody get the consistency mister he
doesn't leave as much in me on there
right when I cook I don't care so much
about it
cavities I go what you want everything
perfect
yeah some people says some people said
that each of their eyes I don't you my
eyes I like when the food looks good
thank you
but it has to taste as good as it looks
so NASA improvise only boom with a group
you know active in America so we're
being sports and stuff like that and
then Jimmy Carter culture that I grew up
in I'm gonna of taking care about it we
love exercise um you know put your good
food uncle juice is annoyed by there and
that's just I grew up on one man like
that my father just our culture and I've
experienced how good food makes me feel
yeah an experience or bad film of a
fever and I prefer how good you feel you
can elicit lifts you up you know so we
have our non-stick pan we put some
coconut oil in there to make it nice of
stuff don't sleep all right let's try
the first one
paramedics all we need is some syrup
Chiana you really sure you want to get
in there they getting on me
good choice justice